as we are going into lizzy shanks there
are ukrainian soldiers pulling out they
are exhausted outnumbered and outgunned
and they're taking a hammering in the
words of their foreign minister they
need weapons weapons and weapons again
and without a new injection of foreign
arms ukrainian forces will not be able
to stop russia's advance in the east
so they're getting people out as quickly
as possible
the elderly are the ones most at risk
and least able but who need the most
persuading to leave
katarina tells us the social worker who
helped her has fled she's 74 and
frightened who wouldn't be
the policeman reassures her she'll get
food and medicine she's been living
alone with her 84 year old husband who
appears to have dementia and they have
little to eat and no power
um
and know their town is next
the cities are the last two holdouts
against russian troops in luhansk once
they fall the whole of one half of the
donbass will be under their enemy's
control
the victims of this brutal war are
piling up from the two areas an
indication of the mass slaughter that's
happened and is still going on here the
police now have the terrible task of
hurriedly laying their fellow citizens
to rest
they're buried in bulk dozens and dozens
stacked in together no time for goodbyes
no time for mourning
there's the stench of putrefying bodies
despite the body bags
this war has stripped the dead and the
living of all humanity
it's been impossible to cope with the
number of dead because of the war and
the battle raging all around and apart
from those that have yet been covered
there are 150
along here they're already digging
more trenches not just this one but also
this huge one because they're expecting
so many more to end up here
i think they're dogs who came here he
says you don't even understand what
they're doing
but there will be revenge for them a
million times over
but even these hurried makeshift burials
are done under fire
lissie shanks has suffered a lot already
and knows there's an even bigger battle
headed their way
and in the aid center they're nearing
total despair
these are syringes without needles this
surgeon says boxes and boxes of
donations they cannot use
will it be helpful for people he asks
most of the aid here will not help at
all
there's hardly any medicine he says we
don't have hospitals no pharmacies no
connection no communications no
logistics unfortunately most of this age
is useless
for those who've made it out of several
donetsk there's some relief reuniting
with loved ones is sweet comfort
they think they're safe now but they've
just found themselves in the next city
the russians have their eyes on
alex crawford sky news in lissy shanks
in the donbass